régulièrement sur cette antenne nous
faisons le point sur vos idées sorties
sur vos loisirs quoi de mieux que les
conseils d'une spécialiste bonjour s'ils
viennent à vous at elle la directrice
d'yveline tourisme quels sont les
ateliers les activités à faire pendant
ces vacances qui se poursuivent on
commence par houdan et part pour le pays
voilà alors au pays ou d'année ce sont
ces 10 et sont les 10 ans de l'office du
tourisme du pays sedanais et pour ça il
ya dix ans dix événements donc on a le
troisième événement là qui ce qui se
passe les 4 et 5 mai prochain donc il ya
tout un tas de choses qui vont être
proposées des randonnées
cyclotouristiques des randonnées vtt des
spectacles de rue des repas produits du
terroir enfin plein d'animations qui
vont être proposées à l'occasion de ses
dix ans jusqu'à la fin de l'année
puisque ça a commencé en mars et ça se
termine en décembre autre idée autre
rendez-vous sortie pour les familles ce
week end le terroir tour oui tour de
france des saveurs et donc ça c'est le
le 4 mai prochain c'est à dire
maintenant c'est au potager du roi et ce
sont onze lycée agricole et viticole qui
se sont associés pour organiser c'est
pas la bonne c'est paul mon visuel sas
et
on va en fait les visuels dans l'ordre
mais c'est pas grave on est un peu
anticipée donc ça se passe au potager du
roi vous allez rencontrer si vous y
venez les professionnels des lycées
agricoles qui vont faire partager leur
passion qui vont vous donner des petits
trucs des petites astuces et qui vous
font partager leur leur connaissance de
tous les produits locaux de toute la
france étaient vifs il sera présent sur
ce terroir tour les images les bonnes
images seront à découvrir dans nos
prochaines éditions à notre tour des
régions mais en chansons cette fois ci
et là le bon visuel s'affichera à tour
des régions de france comté c'est ça et
ça c'est ta france miniature donc ça
c'était la bonne lebon visuel qui
étaient là à france miniature vous avez
une conteuse qui va venir vous parler de
cons d'anecdotes
de plein de choses qui fait qu'ils font
un peu rêver elle s'appelle le stéphanie
fleury et donc on vous propose tout ça
les 5 9 et 10 mai prochains donc c'est
pendant les vacances scolaires une fois
de plus il faut profiter de cette
occasion pour découvrir france miniature
pas comme d'habitude plus classique
peut-être plus fatigant aussi pour les
enfants qui sont agités le parc
multijeux oui mais là ils pourront se
dépenser pour alain ferrand donc ça
c'est à la base de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines ya des trampolines
des cartes des structures gonflables
c'est pendant toutes les vacances
scolaires pendant les jours fériés les
week-ends et les mercredis où les
enfants pourront se défouler un petit
peu de toute l'énergie qu'ils ont en eux
et dieu sait s'ils en ont en général
donc une bonne occasion pour les mamans
de pouvoir un peu se libérer voilà les
enfants aussi peuvent devenir barman et
c'est sans modération alors ça c'est
encore autre chose c'est au trianon
palace à versailles
le l'hôtel a effectivement un bar qui
s'appelle lever et dans ce bar on
propose aux enfants d'être le barman
d'un jour et il sait de 13 à 15 heures
tous les dimanche et va repartir avec
son petit diplôme et il pourra
évidemment faire des cocktails sans
alcool avec des jus de fruits des sirops
des brochettes de fruits avec des jolis
verres à pied va découvrir tout ça
peut-être qu'ils vont se trouver
un métier d'avenir on ne sait pas en
tout cas ils auront leurs petits
diplômes et les parents sont contents de
voir leurs enfants ravis de faire des
nouveautés c'est gratuit et c'est
précieux insistons dessus et ce dernier
rendez-vous pour terminer ce qui te
complète vos activités pour les vacances
une découverte du monde équestre oui
alors ça c'est au haras national des
bréviaires le haras national des
bréviaires il se situe non loin de
rambouillet et c'est le seul haras
national en france où vous pouvez
découvrir les pur-sang les pur-sang qui
propose un spectacle
qu'ils soient des spectacles montés ou
des spectacles en liberté ensuite après
après ce spectacle où l'on découvre les
pur sang du du haras national on pourra
effectivement avoir la possibilité
d'aller à des ateliers atelier pour les
pour les enfants et puis ensuite on
visitera la sellerie et puis les
différentes salles où se trouve se
trouvent les chevaux on peut rester
drôle dans le monde du cheval comme ça
tout un après-midi voilà pour les
activités des vacances on va profiter de
votre présence également pour évoquer
vers les yvelines c'est le nouvel
événement divine tourisme ça débute le
18 mai absolument l'objectif de ce
rendez vous alors l'objectif de ces de
ce rendez vous c'est de montrer toute la
partie verte du département puisqu'on
est le poumon vert de l'île de fond
c'est comme ça qu'on nous appelle on a
quand même 70 mille hectares d'espacés
boisés des des endroits où on peut
facilement se ressourcer et en plus
découvrir des petits coins merveilleux
avec des petites églises des lavoirs des
producteurs de du terroir et puis aussi
quelques quelques grands sites donc cet
événement c'est découvrir tout ça en
randonnant alors que ça soit en
randonnant à pied aussi bien aussi à
cheval ou ou également à vélo et donc il
y aura une cinquantaine de randonnée qui
sont proposés sur trois semaines donc dû
18 mai au 2 juin avec des randonnées
phare que nous organisons d'où ils
viennent tourisme une à cheval une à
pied une cyclo avec des thématiques donc
c'est pas la randonnée bien bête où on
marche et puis c'est tout c'est la
randonnée animée donc c'est pas la
petite randonnée organisée par le club
uniquement c'est aussi des randonnées
pour les familles de façon à rendre
abordable cette activité a à tout le
monde et pour découvrir toutes les
richesses du territoire avec ses membres
et des yvelines vous reviendrai sur le
plateau on détaillera justement ce
programme est ce que vous connaissez le
domaine de physio police de trial et je
connais et dont on parlait tout à
l'heure puisque c'est l'objet d'un
documentaire il sera diffusé sur tv fils
est les réalisateurs vont me rejoindre
dans quelques minutes merci suivi la
luna vos conseils vos idées sorties je
le précise un sont aussi à retrouver sur
notre site internet avec le un fameux
replay nous